mari mari mari mari mari mari se la zia
ti chiede qualcosa non sono stato io a
rompere il bicchiere di là non sono
stato io ok ok va bene
voglio sapere chi è stato a rompere il mio
bicchiere è stato lui ma guarda che hai
proprio una bella faccia tosta ma lo
sappiamo tutti che sei tu la maldestra
di questa casa è inutile che piagnucoli
ma guarda mari mari dai vieni dai
andiamo di là tutti che si giochiamo a carte insieme con tutti gli altri
io devo finire di studiare ma come dai
che studiare da ora che siamo tutti
insieme andiamo prendere un gelato dopo mi dispiace dopo inizia il documentario di
alberto angela e non me lo perderei per
niente al mondo
gli zii mi hanno detto che sto benissimo con questi capelli
a me hanno detto che sono la più bella
della famiglia ma mi raccomando eh non
dire che te l'ho detto
comunque ho perso tre chili
solo io ne ho persi 10 e ho raggiunto il
mio peso forma ideale beata te comunque
non so se lo sai ma ho fatto un servizio
fotografico
sì sì l'ho visto io invece ho iniziato a
sfilare... per victoria's secret
fate i bravi voi due non litigate si mamma
tranquilla ciao zia
non ti preoccupare lasciamo il telecomando devo guardare gossip girl
non voglio vedere gossip girl
c'é l'ultima del trono di spade lasciamelo dammelo
mari ma basta studiare é sabato sera
metti giù quel libro usciamo un pó dai
no io con te non ci esco perché tu il
sabato sera vai in discoteca e mamma dice
che discoteca ci sta il diavolo ma non
vado in discoteca non ti porto in
discoteca non ci vado neanche più in
discoteca senti senti che programmino
top io e te da soli drink analcolico e
poi cinemino gli avengers che ti
piacciono tanto eh belli gli avengers va bene vado a prepararmi brava brava vai
matti l'ho convinta é dei nostri stasera la
cuginetta si ubriaca in una maniera
assurda mari mi presti il tuo vestito
nero per favore sì va bene allora tu
prestami la tua borsa di paillettes va
bene ok  un'altra cosa hai presente le
scarpe che indossava ieri sera le
balenciaga esatto non è che mi presteresti
anche quelle scordatelo assolutamente no però pensandoci bene se mi prestassi la tua
borsa di prada
potrei farci un pensierino
edo edo facciamo uno scherzo a zia maria allora sai che lei é fissata con le
canottiere di lana che c'ha la sua
collezione
noi andiamo nel suo armadio gliele prendiamo gliele buttiamo lei domani si sveglia
non le trova e impazzisce
ma mari ma zia maria ma è vecchia ma
poverina può rimanerci sotto da un
momento all'altro ma va la ma chi è la mia cuginetta
preferita eh dai cosa hai fatto oggi a
scuola qual è la tua materia preferita
noooo mammaaaaa ziaaa
guarda che graziosa questa fascia fa
molto riviera molto Saint Tropez molto
Antibes comunque a proposito di vacanze e
prossima settimana vado alle Maldive
perché mani mi vede che sono un
pó stressata in vista della maturità allora ha detto amore ti porto a rilassare quando
torno poi mi vuole regalare la macchina
peró mi ha mandato in paranoia perché quale
scelgo la lambo o la ferra tu che
faresti scusa che cos'è la ferra ma la
ferrari no dai
guarda non lo so perché io giro in
monopattino poverino mi dispiace fai
parte delle parte povera della famiglia
questo sorrisetto eh con chi ti stai sentendo niente con marco marco ancora tuo cugino
ma vuoi capire che non è normale mari ma siamo cugini di secondo grado non c'è scritto da
nessuna parte che se si é cugini di secondo grado
non si può flirtare questo è palese
incesto ma palese proprio edo ma se ti
chiedessi una cosa no
é vero che non glielo vai a raccontare a
mamma che cosa ce l'hai una sigaretta per me che le ho finite ahhh la cuginetta ha iniziato a
fumare eh sembrava ieri che eri alta cosi
comunque no non fumo mi spiace sigarette
perché in compenso ho questa una bella
bomba venuta direttamente da amsterdam
dai dai dai apri la finestra che ce la fumiamo
insieme ma tu sei pazzo io non le faccio queste cose buon compleanno zia cos'hai fatto di buono da
mangiare
la lasagna le parmigiane buon natale
famiglia ciao quanto tempo finalmente ti
fai vedere eh si dove sono i regali
eccoci purtroppo arrivati alla fine del
video spero tantissimo che vi sia
piaciuto mi raccomando fatemi sapere con
un commentino qui sotto quali di questi
cugini siete o quali di questi cugini
avete e se il video arriverà 60.000
like girerò la seconda parte quindi
spolliciate tutti e se non l'avete ancora
fatto iscrivetevi al mio canale e seguitemi
su tutti gli altri social facebook
instagram e tiktok vi mando un bacione enorme
e ci vediamo al prossimo video